From untouched coastline to tropical forests and age-old fishing villages, the best
place to behold the jewels of Zanzibar is
from the sky.
But now we also know how quick those jewels
are disappearing.
Computer scientists from the University of
Zanzibar are using drones to take pictures
of every centimeter of the isles.
They hope the images will encourage people
to pursue more responsible developments.
“We believe there are thresholds to the
environment.
There are limits.
You may have the numbers of hotels, but if
you don’t where they are, or what interference
they have on the water and the people, and
what was before - maybe there was a forest?
So the information is good - because we want to balance. We're talking about responsible tourism.”
“The maps that these drones create are
more than 25 times more detailed than those
of Google.
It allows these technicians to see Zanzibar in a way no scientist nor Government has ever
seen before.
And they hope that will expand these
isles horizons.”
The tens of thousands of drone photos are
meshed together to create stunning 3D maps.
They could help authorities work out where
buildings are going up too fast.
Like this area, where they took two images
just six months apart.
“So if you look in a small area like this
one.
And then we came up to take another image
to see what has changed.
So the green is running out in Zanzibar - we
want to prevent that.”
“It changed me to understand that I need
to do something for my myself.
I need to tell people that how we are building
- it’s really not good.
We are destroying our own environment.”
It is not only a question of beauty.
Poor infrastructure and planning ruins lives
in Zanzibar.
Annual floods frequently kill people and submerge
neighbourhoods for days on end.
“I thank god the floods haven’t killed
anybody in our neighbourhood.
But they destroy our property and people have
to leave their houses.
They lose possessions, beds, all sorts of
things.
And we are poor people, it takes us a long
time to recover.”
The researchers say they will supply their
maps to all relevant authorities
- and empower communities to hold people accountable.
So while beauty lies in the eye of the beholder,
Its preservation may lie much higher up.